This video is brought to you by keeps
what's up. Wisecrack Michael here,
have you ever wondered if innovation and technology are ever going to backfire
and destroy humanity?
And just because science could do something incredible that it actually should
and once and for all,
can anyone explain the difference between animatronics and auto erotica? Well,
on this episode of the good, the bad and the brilliant,
we're going to try to answer these questions by breaking down the 1993 classic
Jurassic park and this film,
we see what happens when an eccentric billionaire plays God and brings dinosaurs
back to life. It does not go well. And to help me,
I am joined by TV writer and performer, Billy domino, Billy, how are you doing.
Well? We've got, you know, the big pandemic outside,
but in here we probably still also have the pandemic.
So it's good to be less than six feet away from you right now.
It's good.
It's good to know that someone statistically speaking in this tiny room that
we're in is probably infected.
Does that ruin the magic of this? To know that this was shot in a room?
Like where people, assuming we exist in this neutral space, it just has some,
you know, primary colored props behind it. Yeah.
Yeah. I mean, I,
I think we think of it as like the movie interstellar where we find the fifth
dimension that this room is a sort of fifth dimension or time in space coalesced
into this corner.
I haven't actually seen interstellar that's McConaughey. Right?
So I've seen a Lincoln commercial and I'm going to take whatever lessons I've
learned from that and say that was interstellar.
It's similar to that. I think, I think Lincoln guy,
Matthew McConaughey starts in interstellar and that character is the one in
those commercials.
It's possible. Uh, Lincoln guy,
Matthew McConaughey got paid more than interstellar guy, Matthew McConaughey.
Oh, that's probably true. So to get started,
let's talk about what's good in this movie.
So give us something what's something you think is good about Jurassic park.
Script.
This movie occupies so much space in my brain for so long.
I've been thinking about it either consciously or unconsciously for 27
years now.
And I can not think of a more robust screenplay that ties up every loose
and that uses everything it puts into play and makes it meaningful.
Nothing is wasted.
It's so efficient and everything has a very big emotional
payoff.
The first thing that comes to mind there for me is all the ways that they start
to hint that, okay, this park is actually not.
What it seems to be is not. It is not as sleek.
It is not as well run as you think it is.
You're getting constant hints throughout it. And it starts in such a small way.
When Donald Genero, the lawyer, the bad guy,
if there is one of this entire movie, he goes to the mind to, you know,
talk to the Amber minors. He gets off this little barge.
He starts walking to the mind and gear. It's totally unacceptable.
And in the middle of talking about this pain lawsuit,
he says the insurance company,
and then he slips on the dirt and he falls down the moment.
The conversation turns to money and not about the safety and logistics.
And should we, or should we not be building this park?
That is when suddenly things start to go awry in the smallest way.
And throughout that, we start to get all these little hints of note to note,
this is not right. This is not.
Yeah. And I think the whole opening,
probably 10 minutes of the film as we bounced to all of our main characters is
so good at setting the stakes for who these people are, what they care about,
how they might eventually bounce off each other. We get the iconic scene of,
of Dr. Grant teaching a young child on a dig site about why we need to take
philosophy Raptors. Seriously. I do wonder why the child is there.
I've always worked from a place of, okay, you see Dr. Grant he's at the screen,
which he shouldn't touch, but he does touch it.
You can't control him and behavior. You know, so humans are the variable,
not the dinosaurs, but look behind him.
And you see a lot of extras doing some really hardcore face acting,
knowing that this is a big budget thing we're going to get on screen.
This is our chance. I've always assumed they are essentially dyno tourists.
They're coming to volunteer at the dig site and help out someone brought their
pudgy little boy along. And he's, you know,
starting to be his own little Dennis, the menace,
he's trying to make a name for himself as well. He has an agent.
The boy needs to eat.
His parents are going to squander the money that he gets from this film.
That's what child acting is.
I love the moment that we have with him when he goes from Turkey to he's very
scared. He's like, yeah, no,
I should give this dinosaur respect because it's 90% fear and
10% me, daddy, like I,
and there's so much sexual awakening for everyone in this movie,
no matter who your favorite star of it is like, I mean,
I am dressed as Laura Durance now I just happen to have this.
I will say you were the first guest on the show.
Who's ever taking things seriously enough to have a tire that relates to
the film.
I would argue I'm the first guest.
That's unemployed enough to be able to go down that road to have the time to
think about how Penn would Mount sambal together. That said, I pray,
I'll take the call.
That was underneath what I was saying, but I tried to have the positive gloss.
But speaking of your outfit,
something I love about this movie and a thing I didn't notice as a kid that I
noticed now, Laura Dern's performance is really phenomenal.
[Inaudible].
As a, I saw this for the first time. I was four years old when it came out.
So I couldn't, I was too young to go see it in the theaters. But you know,
when it came on video, my dad brought home.
We watched it and it was a sexual awakening. First of all, I will say that,
but it wasn't sexual on top of my brain. Like I would like to kiss Laura dirt.
It was just like, that is what a nice wife is. Like,
that's the process my brain went through and it informed all of my
future sexual thinking up until the time I saw like Daria five years later,
and then like, Oh, maybe that at least first.
I'm not miserable. I'm just not like them.
I wish that I was a licensed psychotherapist.
Cause I would love to go through the journey of Laura Dern, Andrew asset park,
being the entry into sexualized fantasizing,
and then Daria an animated outsider picking up that mantle.
This is all very interesting stuff. Well,
what's another thing that stands out to you as being good.
Or movie that is all about spectacle.
At least when you're pitching it and you're selling to an audience, you know,
we're going to see dinosaurs. And for the first time in movie history,
they're going to look good and real. And they're going to have this.
They're going to bring about this amazing emotional reaction from you.
The audience, it is grounded in so many intricate,
emotional arcs. You have the most prominent one is Dr. Grant going from,
we were talking about, you know,
six foot Turkey kid and him being very aggressive and wanting to stave off the
idea of fatherhood and maturity and having to potentially put aside, you know,
bachelorhood style dreams. He goes from having the Raptor, claw out.
His knives are out. And then by the time we get to the end of,
I think this is a five act movie.
I'll make that argument at the end of act three,
when we're going up into the tree, he sits down out. I hurt my.
It's because of the claw. Oh, my insecurities are holding me back.
I'm going to get rid of my insecurities and move on with my life.
That's great. And then even the,
I think the final time we see him in the movie is with Tim and Lex asleep on his
shoulders, in the helicopter.
And where does he look to? He looks out and he sees birds.
Birds are dinosaurs in his brain. And he realizes, Oh yes,
I have to give up the Peter pan fantasy of living in dinosaur land,
but I can always take it with me.
And I'm still going to be me at my core as a bird is still a dinosaur.
Yeah.
And this has made me think I wrote something down that felt ludicrous as I was
writing it, but I want to defend.
Now there's something symphonic about the movie in which all these
interconnected parts always hit at the right moment. Come together.
Not when you think they should, but when they actually should, as well.
I was using the word symphonic F first of all,
is it okay that I'm waving this pen around? This feels like violence.
As I'm like throwing it back and forth. I do feel threatened. Great.
This is the first time as a child that I ever cared about music in a
film to this day. I think it is the greatest film score I've ever heard.
You have the Nana, that's the main theme. You have the adventure theme, duh,
duh, duh.
And then you have the rafter theme as well for the moments of extreme danger.
I don't even know the notes to that one.
The main theme I will argue to this day,
it's the perfect thing to walk down the aisle to in fact,
a former partner stole that from me. It's okay.
Understand you liked a good idea. That's fine. You know what? It wasn't for it.
Wasn't for me to say whether my future wife will, you know, we'll use that. Um,
we'll say that is one piece of music where it's just like, Oh,
I want to go on this journey right now.
It's this beautifully sad melancholic piece of it
is you are listening to a beautiful dream and the notes and are constantly mind
you that this is so wonderful. And yes, it is a dream.
This can never be had it's in the past, but try if you want to, you know,
go through that, that emotional heartbreak you're well,
you're welcome to remember the dream.
Yeah. Now I feel like we could go on with the good for this for quite some time,
I'm going to hit a couple of things real quick.
You can agree or disagree before we end this,
the CGI and animatronics 27 years old holdup, doesn't take you out of it.
I also think it's cool that this movie got an entire generation largely.
I'm sure our generation excited about dinosaurs and into science.
And I also think through the eyes of the children, the movie,
and this is a very Spielberg thing, captures a sense of childlike,
wonder in a way that doesn't feel forced or gimmicky.
And I think that really catches you in the film.
Who's watching. This probably has seen it multiple times.
It's probably been many years since you saw it. The first time,
it is hard to overstate the magnitude of the shot when Dr. Grant and
Ellie first see the BRACA sores,
because it's both for the audience and Dr. Grant are going through the same
thing there for Dr. Grant. It is not just, Oh, here's a dream.
I've had my entire life, but I'll probably never get it.
Like if your dream was to make a billion dollars, yes, it's possible,
but it's not going to happen, but it's still possible.
This is a dream he has always had and always accepted will never come true.
And now you just broke his brain and his heart by saying, actually surprise.
This can be real. And you know, on a much smaller level,
I don't think audiences had ever anticipated,
seen a dinosaur that looks so right.
Perfect time to put a little bow on our good discussion and transition to the
bed. So what is something that you find bad about your part,
but before we continue, I want to give a shout out to this week's sponsor keeps,
did you know that two out of three guys will experience some form of male
pattern baldness by the time they're 35, it sucks.
And unfortunately avoiding the sun wearing hats or cutting down on shower time,
doesn't stop it.
Still prevention is the key and keeps treatments work to help you keep your
hair. The sooner you start, the more hair you will save.
66% of men even experienced hair.
Regrowth keeps us revolutionize the way men are treated for hair loss with keeps
it's easier and more affordable to get treatment.
They offer products that are FDA approved and available over the counter or with
the prescription.
You simply visit a doctor online and get the medication delivered right to your
home. It's so simple and easy.
So if you're noticing hair loss and they're stressing,
do something about it for a limited time,
go to keeps.com/wisecrack or click the link in the description to get 50%
off your first order. Now, back to the show.
First thing I'll say,
and this is a critique of Spielberg movies more in general than is this one
we're lacking moral ambiguity.
Even though there is a whole question throughout this of, is it right?
Is it wrong to bring back dinosaurs?
Is it right to think that we can possibly control them?
Or is it utter folly from the beginning in the end,
the answers are all pretty clear to that.
Or at least the answers to the movie presents to us.
And we know where characters fall. It's not pure black and white,
but it is a very linear spectrum.
And I'd love some extra dimensionality or some ambiguity there.
That could be fun. That said, I don't even know if I wanted,
would that make it a totally different movie? Yeah.
Yeah, no, I think, I think you're right there.
This is so much more minor than that.
Something that I think is bad or questionable,
a crazy old billionaire invites his grandchildren to test out a
dinosaur park.
Like he doesn't think let's get some weird employees or like pay some orphans,
his own blood. He wants them to be the test subjects.
Like what did he tell his children that sent them?
Like if child protective services heard about this, what would happen?
And they're in an international situation as well.
I think that's kind of reckless and I can't, I can't help. But think about that.
I think about that a lot too. And there are two sides to it. One is the,
I don't believe it. And I'm with you on that.
I think he's smart enough to know this is not the time.
Although they do set up the idea of his daughter is getting a divorce.
So he's clearly just trying to take their minds off. It.
Have to leave early. He wants to be with his daughter, she's getting a divorce.
So what he Hammond lacks at all times is a respect
for the variables he's introducing into this equation.
He doesn't recognize that just by brain into extra bodies that is going to
have different effects on the system as well.
Yeah. I mean,
I'm glad they're there because Tim and Lex bring a lot to the film. Uh,
the only other thing, and this is in a similar boat that I don't like so much,
this staff seems kind of dumb.
Is he dilated? You should know this.
I'm confused about that side has to, does he,
after dropping her back at the compound,
does he then get to the boat in time or is he just in his own little bunker the
whole time? I feel like he disappears, honestly. Yeah.
Why is he just assuming again,
everyone says there is a problem on this Island that overall comes back to the
good side of this.
Everyone assumes that the dinosaurs and the employees will behave
lawfully and they just assume no, no,
that won't be a problem because we hope it won't be.
And it's just another way that we learn, okay, no, this park is not control.
I'm not like this goes back to that earlier point I was making.
But during the Mr. DNA sequence, the best exposition in any movie of all time,
period, they scientists decide, no,
we want to get off the ride now bar up and are able to escape it.
Can they do that? If you can not control people, how can you control dinosaurs?
And it's a perfect illustration of that. Another thing I've got on here,
I don't love. And again, this is almost more of a Spielberg commentary.
I don't love the dinosaur sneeze.
I don't need the brackets are sneezing on legs. And I get that. It is for kids.
It's a lot like the scene in temple of doom when they're ha they first get to
the palace and like, Oh, we're having a great feast for you tonight.
And it's just a quick gross at the moment,
knowing that a lot of your audience is seven years old,
but I personally think there are better ways to appeal to kids and just have a
dinosaur season, especially when it's the worst amatronic of the entire movie.
And then if you hypothetically were to rewatch this movie during a global
pandemic, that involves the potential of coughing on people.
It added an extra layer. When I saw that,
cause I imagined an infected dinosaur coughing on me and she's covered with it
like slime. And then as a clean freak, I think there's no towels.
There's no like wet wipes. She's just out here.
If she cleaned it off at all, it was back in that like runoff, sewer,
where she was hiding during the car sequins. And who's to say,
that's not filled with GRD from like, we don't have the answers to that,
but I'm glad we agreed on this. You know, we can shake on it. Nope, Nope.
Not going to shake on it. Nope. I will probably cut that.
I didn't like that bit around.
Cut it. Cause you said we shouldn't and then it'll be a joke on your behalf.
Anything else you think is bad about this movie?
I think there are a couple moments, even though we have the Mr. DNA, uh,
sequence, which is perfect exposition,
there are a couple moments of exposition that I don't love so much,
which is T-Rex his vision is based on movement. You start saying that early on,
we say it five different times. So I appreciate like the brute force of it,
but it's still something that's just like, okay,
you clearly just need this for a plot element.
Since learned is not true. Uh, yeah. That's uh,
that's one of the dinosaur facts that isn't true. Uh,
their eyes were actually more straight ahead than on the sides.
So there's no good evidence right now that that's how T-Rex I worked
well. They also had feathers, any last bad things that you can muster.
Lastly.
And I'll point out is the I'm calling this financial continuity in that,
uh, scene that we get, which is like the long dark night of the soul,
where you have Dern and Attenborough talking in the cafeteria,
they're eating melting ice cream because it would go to waste.
Otherwise that is like,
that's the ice cream that you go to Kroger and get it's a six gallon. Yeah.
It's like, and sure, it's delicious. I will eat that all day.
But a guy is saying spared, no expense.
As his catchphrase on this Island is spared expense on the ice cream.
And Laura, Darren has a vine and she goes, no, it's not, no way, no way.
It's good at all. Plain vanilla. It's not even vanilla beam.
Like I can enjoy that,
but it's not good to compare that to the cake buffet that the children enjoy
later. There's like a French patisseries somewhere on this Island.
Why would you make all that? You know, that there's like six people here.
That's where I do like the kid acting on the kid jokes,
Timmy grabbing two serving spades and just be like almost ready to
sharpen them against each other.
Before we get to the brilliant, let's have a little fun.
We're going to do the lightning round now where we can ask each other questions
that are related or kind of related to the movie, we'll go back and forth,
but you can start first. So, uh, what's your first question.
So we've already gone over lard Dern in this movie was a sexual awakening for
me. Uh,
what movie or TV character at some point served as a real
bounce for your sexual understanding?
Uh, Madonna. And I'm pretty sure it was the,
like a prayer video because one of the first dreams I ever had in life that was
at all sexual involve Madonna. And as a kid,
I was just confused about what it meant,
but I think that was the first time my unconscious was sexually active.
And it's beautiful. If you had to go on a deep jungle adventure,
which character do you take with you and why?
I'm just going to go with Muldoon because this is a man who has a dark history
clearly. Yes. Uh, and he's also capable with a gun until he's not.
So I'm taking them.
We can say iconic lines from this guy,
clever girl and shoot her very iconic.
He did a lot with a little in this film.
So Jurassic park had a ton of toys and merchandising so much that they even
referenced it in the movie before the movie came out.
By seeing that star to the gift shop.
Is there a movie or other media property that you think should have had
more toys associated with?
It there'll be a lot of fun for us to play with those kids or adults. Okay.
Yeah. This one kind of toys, but maybe an overall aesthetic.
I think the Royal Tenenbaums. So like you could have the outfits,
you could have like a children's book with paintings in that style.
You could even do like a kind of tweet,
like a record player for someone's house.
I just think you could have got a lot of leverage out of that.
And I think that's evidenced by how many people still use that as inspiration
for like Halloween costumes every year.
So he could have really teamed up with urban Outfitters on that one.
Wes Anderson missed out on buckets of money with that idiot.
What animal or creature in general would you bring back from extinction?
Can't be dinosaurs.
The first thing that's coming to mind is a cave bear.
I'm one of those big macro faunas from, you know,
before from around the last ice age,
we know that Jurassic park doesn't turn out well,
but let's say this is happening in real life.
And you even know all these consequences. Do you still,
as whether the president or chief investor say, let's try it.
I think we can do it this time.
I still think I would.
There's something about dinosaurs and space travel or those two things that the
kid brain and all of us can't say no to too exciting.
What do you think dinosaur meat tastes like?
So it's reptile the easy comp there is alligator.
If anyone has not had alligator,
it's the simple comp there is just chicken meats, fish. And I love frog.
I love alligator. And on the amphibian side, like frog legs.
And because these are mutated dinosaurs who are part frog, there we go.
So it's a very white meat, almost translucent, probably.
Although you could get some red meat, like on a bigger carnivore. Yeah.
Yeah.
So we want a Cajun chef on this because they would have the experience with
alligators and frogs.
The easy answer is you get surf blackened.
Thank you for that. That was a very fun lightning round.
And I appreciate all the prep that went into that on your end.
There's so much mutual respect here. A lot of respect. I feel it.
So now that we've done good,
bad and lightening round it's time to get into the parts of the movie that make
us think the real big questions for us. That's the brilliant section.
So what is something from Jurassic park that you think deserves the title of
brilliant?
Let's just start with the core of this movie thematically.
The idea that the brute force of nature will always try humph
over intellect. And we're seeing that on every,
every time someone fails in this movie,
pretty much it's because they thought they could outsmart the just basic forces
of nature, whether it's ham and thinking, I can control these bees,
whether it is Nedjeree thinking, Oh,
I can create a computer virus and I can escape the Island, but no,
the typhoon gets in his way. Uh,
and he was never even planning for that in the first place.
Even one of my favorite shots in this movie has always been when the Raptors are
attacking the control room and you see from the, probably the Mr.
DNA shows going up and you see the genetic code projected onto the raft.
And just like, I love that.
I don't know if I'm fully appreciate everything that's going there and I'm going
to take a stab at it after watching it last night,
the idea is the Raptor is so smart right now. And,
but even that brilliance is born of nature.
So the reason you can never use brilliant out smart nature is because it's
coming back from that same source and it's going to bowl you over.
Well. Yeah. And I think like that, so much of that is summed up in Malcolm's.
You know, life finds a way quote.
Implying that a group composed entirely of female animals will breed.
No, I'm simply saying that life finds a way.
And I think that says a lot about how like organic matter and organic life is
something that in so much as humans have constantly tried to control it,
we just can't. Um,
every single time humans have the hubris to think that we can control where
water is flowing or the temperature in a certain place,
or what livestock grows here or there, things can take us out.
Even a small virus that we can't even see could potentially have a life altering
effect on an entire planet. Hypothetic you're talking about,
I'm just spit balling. I saw a contagion recently. It seems like a fun,
fictional idea. I think the movie,
a lot of the questions it brings up are just as relevant,
if not more relevant now than they were then. So, you know,
I've written down whether it's genetic engineering, cloning and,
and the big idea of humans modifying nature, um,
and that weird kind of paradox of humans being natural entities,
which via our weird,
up reason are now trying to go backwards and change the same natural
processes that led to us. It seems not good.
It's an, obviously there, you're getting into the Lord Dern quote, the,
you know, God creates dinosaur has got a story's dinosaurs,
or I guess it starts with Sam Neill. That's okay. No,
it starts with Ian Malcolm, who is Jeff Goldbloom.
There are too many names in the world.
Destroys dinosaur. God creates man,
man destroys God man creates
eat. Man.
This movie is constantly obsessed with the idea of what is
that force that is causing sort of regeneration and destruction and rebuilding.
And can you ever, you know, as I started saying earlier,
can you ever sort of come out on top of that? Can you beat it in the long run?
And the very clear answer seems to be no,
but what you can do with grant and the pelicans, he's looking at the end,
you can decide I'm going to kind of go with the flow here and see if I can ride
that out too.
Yeah. And I think that the quote you mentioned before, that's, uh, the,
to partner with Malcolm and in the Lord during character, when it's sort of,
you know, uh, God grades, dinosaurs kills dinosaurs creates man, the,
the important part views. And it says, man kills God. So I think without that,
the film wouldn't be as poignant,
but the idea that humans have killed off the idea of something that's more
powerful than them outside of them.
And the killing of God gives them the ability to think that we are God and we
can create things which makes me then think about the way in which human
innovation can lead or sow the seeds at least to self extinction. Yeah.
And.
You also have the quote. I love the scene so much.
It's after the rafter feeding, they go into like, okay, let's eat our lunch now.
And they are in this board room,
which is just dark and Scott projectors going around,
like it's oddly reminiscent of like the Dr. Strange love more room almost.
And the idea is, okay,
we're now going to have a rational discussion about the entire problem of the
park.
And we're going to look at all entirely through financial terms with projections
of future revenue and stuff like that. Malcolm calls out to John Hammond.
He's like, you didn't actually do most of this work.
You stood on the shoulders of giants.
And there's a real big thing throughout this movie of one.
When he shows up he's in pure white,
he's not dirty by the dig site or any other work he's ever done.
This is a movie that is entirely about digging.
You dig into the ground to find the rock.
You dig into the rock to find the mosquito into mosquito, to find the blood,
to find the DNA, and then to blow that back up into a dinosaur.
And he is someone who is in even a neutral sense of term. He's a confidence,
man. He's just the music man style salesman saying,
I can sell this to you and everyone get behind me.
And because he is not directly involved with any of the processes,
he never has an appreciation for what could go wrong and why that's
important.
Well, exactly. I think there's a theme too,
of people that have the power to make modifications to nature or innovate new
technologies are often the types of people that aren't physically doing those
things and might not have to live with the consequences.
So whether it's like an industrialization building these awesome factories and
not realizing that the waste of those factories would poison drinking water for
generations and kill off people,
whether it's the way in which we've used various sources of energy to now
drastically change the ecosystem of our actual planet.
Most of these things are done without thinking through the potential
implications of them. And by the time we realize it it's too late.
So we already talked a little bit about, um,
Alan Grant's arc from, you know, essentially, uh,
put off bachelor to family, man.
We're also dealing with other family themes in there and I'm,
it's cool that it's able to tackle complex ideas in very small ways.
I really think that there's a big theme of PTSD going on in here with the kids,
especially with Lex. I, my friends do not agree with this.
I'm going to still make the argument.
Now that I have a platform when Lex screams,
she's talking about Janeiro for Donald and after getting out of the car.
But whether she realized she's actually talking about her dad,
who we know is getting divorced divorce from her mom,
and she's just processing that in the moment.
And now she's having this awful catharsis. I mean.
Sigmund Freud would a hundred percent agree with you that that is what's
happening there. So I think that's a valid reading and I think any abilities,
friends who make them feel that about that reading should read a book. No,
I think that's a really cool reading.
And one of the only other things I'm thinking about for brilliant,
and I think Malcolm gives this speech at the end,
the could and should distinction, which touches on what we're already saying.
But when he says to Hammond, you know, you only thought about,
could you do this? Not, should you do this?
We're so preoccupied with whether or not they could.
They just have to think if they should.
It becomes this sort of intellectualized game of just,
that is entirely about outcomes rather than the process and how that influences
and informs potential outcomes.
And I even love when Ian Malcolm is after he explains the basics of chaos to us
and he references, you know, the, the butterfly theory.
There's the butterfly effect, a butterfly flap,
its wings contain in central pocket that rain instead, essentially he.
So immediately,
we're starting to see examples of how this is occurring in the
park five seconds after he says that we're trying to get our seatbelts on as the
helicopter descends. And Oh, no, we both got the wrong ends.
That's just the result of chaotic inputs.
If they sit slightly different to the left or the right,
then we get the right seat belt. But because humans can't be controlled,
they're the variable that you insert into this.
And that's what makes the park so dangerous.
It's our own actions that we presume are going to be safe and effective. I mean,
honestly, it's the same thing that you get with something like a pandemic,
you know, that we should shut down, you know,
public areas and everyone should wash their hands. But when you personally,
you know, don't wash your hands for one second, that I'm probably okay,
I'm not going to be the one who gets it.
And just when you look at that in aggregate, then you get portable.
So two things, if you need it. Oh my God, I'm so hungry. Yeah.
I'm going to just do that as well. But along with that, I mean,
I think another thing and they made this is getting meta with the film here is
that all of the things we're talking about are just as relevant and interesting.
Now, 27 years later as they were,
when the film came out and in watching the film,
it's not like these ideas are antiquated or of another era.
And I think that speaks to another reason why this film overall is so good.
Um, I think we've gotten a lot of meat off that bone.
Any other brilliant things you wanna throw out before we wrap up?
There are themes. I, I.
I'm not going to feel qualified to talk about right now,
but I had never noticed them before that there's a real colonial streak here,
looking at Hammond and Muldoon, as you know, colonial enemies, you know,
there's explicit references to, we've done this type of work in Kenya before.
Can spare no expense, make the one I've gotten down in Kenya,
looked like a petting zoo.
We have, uh, both of them in classic. You know,
all they're missing is the pith helmet, you know, for, you know,
English colonial garb. But the idea of we're not just doing this as, you know,
scientists bringing animals back to life. It's really,
we are transporting ourselves to their world and then we are imposing new rules
upon it. And you see this back in that boardroom scene,
Hammond keeps using the word discovery.
We stand in the lines of discovery.
It's not just about, you know,
the work it is about actually transporting themselves and body and mind to a
different place and making it their own.
And I w I want to know what the intention is there behind that and what it
really, you know, has saved it.
Or if it's just sort of a passing nod to the hubris of colonialism.
Once again,
I love that about this movie that we can keep finding stuff like that.
And I think on rewatch is we'll continue to find stuff like that. I literally.
Have every six months,
a moment in the shower where Jurassic park comes to mind and I realized the
connection like truly, and then I just,
I will like slap the door in the shower and be like, Oh my God,
that was intentional. They meant to do that. That's amazing.
Okay. Bailey, we've talked about what's good,
bad and brilliant about Jurassic park did a little lightning round.
Let's reduce all of that discussion. Now do a simple three part rating system.
Do you think Jurassic park is good, bad.
Brilliant. I am going to sum it up as brilliant.
I think the fact that it is able to take so many complicated and moving pieces.
Not only make them work as a whole,
but do so with a whole that is so consumable.
Anyone can watch this movie and love it.
Whether it's purely as a dinosaur movie,
whether you like all the subplots in it,
everyone wants to see this movie and everyone will enjoy it and then can get all
the extra stuff as they go through it. Yeah.
Yeah. Because of everything you just said,
I also think Jurassic park is brilliant.
And I think another piece of evidence to that is I saw this movie when my age
was in the single digits. I don't know how many times I've seen it in my life,
but rewatching it now, 27 years later, it's still great.
I still enjoy it as is evidenced by this conversation.
There's still new stuff to think about. So like, it's a brilliant movie,
so we've done it all. We've talked about the movie we've rated the movie.
It's time to wrap things up. Um,
and so normally we do a little recommended reading viewing section here.
I'm pretty sure neither of us are well-read and paleontology or
dinosaur biology.
Poorly read across the spectrum. I.
Assumed if it didn't want to say anything.
So how about we just say another movie that we think has that
same Jurassic park vibe, something from the eighties or nineties,
really tight script, something you could watch over and over again.
I'll let you go first.
What's another movie that exists in this universe that people should watch.
If they haven't.
If somehow they haven't seen it, they should watch Indiana Jones.
And the last crusade, also a Spielberg,
because everything that I love about Jurassic park,
in terms of all the payoffs you get with Grant's journey, with a scene,
chaos theory, take hold of the, of Jurassic park.
You get that instead of having a bunch of storylines,
you get that in one emotional line that pays off in the biggest way of any movie
I've ever seen in the most elegant sentence or two possible all movie long
Indiana Jones is trying to win the approval of his father,
whether he recognizes it or not.
And we always know that his father does not see Indiana on Indiana's terms
because he doesn't call him Indiana, his nickname. He calls him.
And at the very end in the, as a template collapsing,
Indiana Jones is reaching for the Holy grail because it represents the
relationship with his father. And if I can get that, I can make you love me.
And Sean Connery says all your hatred of yourself, all your hatred of may,
all the anger, all the need to win my approval, let it go, let it go.
They get out of there. They win and everyone's heart is healed.
That's so good.
I'm going to be so much less articulate and interesting with mine,
but I will say if you either haven't seen it or haven't seen it in awhile, uh,
check out the original back to the future movie.
I think that it something interesting in that it's a movie about time travel.
That's not really about time travel. They don't get too hung up on all that.
It's really about like a teen finding himself, figuring out who he is,
navigating some issues with his relationship to his family.
Having fun with an edible complex, having fun.
Of that edible complex, almost making out this mom just great stuff. Um,
but I think it really does hold up.
And the movie avoids getting too caught up in the science-y parts of it.
It's also funny and I enjoy a movie that's, that's funny. Sometimes.
The speakers are loud and they're so loud that they lift them off the ground.
And that happens to me.
No, that's the thing that happens all the time. Um, well, this is great. Uh,
thank you so much for being here. Really appreciate it, Billy.
If people want more of you in their lives after seeing this,
where can they find.
They can find me on Twitter at Billy domino and you can see the scripts that I
write. I put them out there because I'm desperate for your approval.
Much like Indiana Jones. So, uh,
B my dad call me at Billy domino on Twitter and, uh, read some scripts.
There'll be fun.
Great. Um, so everyone, thank you so much for watching.
Remember to be Billy's dad, if you can,
and let us know what you like in the comments,
let us know what you want to see us cover more of let us know you don't want to
see us cover. Don't do that. Let us know you want to see us cover.
Thank you so much for watching. This has been the good,
the bad and the brilliant later.
[Inaudible].